we can head to mexico city now and speak
to the journalist and author ewan griot
great to have you on the program thank
you very much for your time matt clearly
he is a big figure but what will be the
impact of his arrest
so in terms of actually stopping drug
trafficking tragically this likely won't
have
a big effect although he's very very
famous one of the most infamous drug
traffickers in mexico in the world
really his heyday was the 1980s you know
when they raided the biggest marijuana
plantation ever belonging to him
and now he's you know since he managed
to likely bribe a judge to get out of
prison he's been more of a a minor
player in actual trafficking itself
and there's many other players out there
so unfortunately the the fentanyl the
crystal meth the heroin the cocaine that
comes through mexico will continue
on the other side in terms of
american mexican relations this is very
important
when you talk to dea agents
the first person they ask about always
is carol quintero they were furious when
he was released in 2013. in the d.a
offices they have these pictures of kiki
camarena he's a martyr for their agency
and they will really put 20 million
dollars
out for awards so this is really
cementing and there's a certain kind of
cold period
between the current mexican president
and washington and the idea if he
wouldn't let da agents work here and
this is really repairing those
relationships
yeah i mean it was really personal
wasn't it this for the for the dea
absolutely i mean this is you know it
was not only a guy who was you know
murdered he was
tortured there was tapes of him being
tortured
um he was um very very heavily beaten
um and his body was left there and there
was a lot of corruption in mexico at the
time there's also many players so this
was a real
grudge they were going after now another
thing is that today um as your report
said he it was also fighting some quite
gruesome turf wars in the northern
mexico i've been working a lot this last
year in sonora state
and that became a bit of a fiefdom for
carol quintero and he was fighting very
much their other cartel members loyal to
the sons of the drug lord el chapo it
became one of the most violent states in
mexico some very horrific gun battles so
maybe this arrest will try and reduce
that violence in sonora state as well
although there's still many players
fighting over this billions of dollars
in trafficking wealth
yeah i mean the arrest happened um
shortly after president biden met with
the president of mexico uh coincidence
uh very hard to see a complete
coincidence in this i mean right before
this visit and as i said there'd been a
slight cold relationship and there was
criticism of mexican president anders
manuel lopez obrador not really
attacking drug cartels allowing them to
operate not really going after them he
had this this famous uh phrase called
hugs not bullets referred to the drug
war
um and then anyway before this meeting
there was suddenly a bunch of very
significant busts including the biggest
bust ever the biggest seizure ever of
fentanyl now fentanyl is an opioid as a
substitute for heroin and that is really
driving a lot of the deaths the overdose
deaths in the united states last year
you saw more than 100 000
overdose deaths in the united states and
fentanyl was the biggest killer mostly
coming through mexico now this is
mind-boggling numbers if you think about
the nightmare of death happening for
this so a lot of uh pressure inside the
united states to pressure mexico to do
this and then suddenly three days after
the meeting you see the arrest of carol
quintero now this brings up the question
did the mexican government know where he
was all the time i just go and get him
or was there new information that came
from in recent days that allowed them to
make this arrest in the north of sinaloa
well it sounds like there's enough in
another book for you uh there just
answering some of those questions um and
what about these 14 people killed in an
av black hawk helicopter crash during
the operation is there thinking that
this was a simple accident or could it
have been something more sinister
i mean it's a concern a bit of something
more sinister now the helicopter crash
was near the uh port of mochis the
seaside town of mochis pretty close to
where uh carol quintero was taken it
looked like it was involved in the
operation now could it just suddenly
crash leaving the operation or was it
shot down or sabotaged in the past uh
cartels have shot down mexican
helicopters there was a famous incident
in 2015 where they shot one down with an
rpg-7 now as well as the 14th dead
there's one person survived and and i
had the chance to speak to some people
who survived the previous 2015
helicopter crash they were living with
very severe burns so also these are very
costly the cost of this drug war for for
mexican forces i mean there's one police
officer shot every day in mexico right
now so it's very very costly for the
country in terms of the deaths happening
involved with this drug war
yeah quinto's story dramatized of course
in the narcos series in 2018 was it was
a pretty accurate portrayal do you think
it's tv it's dramatic tv and obviously
the first season of narcos mexico was
precisely about this asian king camarena
it had an actor playing carol quintero
and had the massive marijuana plantation
so a lot of the facts are there now
obviously when you spend i spent 21
years covering this as a journalist you
start to see a lot of holes and
inaccuracies and you can see little
things
and one thing about the series it does
very much i would say glamorize the kind
of high life of these drug traffickers
the big players when really a lot of the
time that the traffickers i speak to the
cicadas the killers that i speak to are
often living quite brutal lives quite
hard lives around death around regret
and then most of them are not living
these big big riches that the few elite
of the the drug cartel capos the leaders
are really living
it's been fascinating talking to you uh
you and just before we let you go do you
ever worry about your safety writing
about these drug lords investigating
them i mean absolutely i think anybody
who spends a lot of time doing this um
you know worries about this
mexico has been one of the worst places
in the world for journalists um i've had
you know two people i've worked with who
have been killed including one good
friend harry valdez who was murdered in
2017.
most of the people who have died have
been mexican nationals uh but at the
same time you can never be you know feel
you're immune to this there's been
plenty of foreigners who have been here
have been killed for just being in the
wrong place at the wrong time so
certainly a concern at the same time um
it's a very very important story i think
it's a very important story to
understand the violence happening in
mexico divide is happening in latin
america and how this could also spread
to other countries around the world
yeah it's been fascinating uh hearing
you uh describe events uh out there you
and griot uh stay safe and thank you
very much for speaking to us
thanks much